Speaker 1: It is my pleasure today to welcome
to the program Professor Olivia Simone at
HGC Paris, as well as coauthor of the book
Noise A Flaw in Human Judgment, co-written
by Daniel Kahneman, as well as Cass Sunstein
case, a multi time guest on the program before
Olivia.
So great to have you on today.
Speaker 5: Thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: So maybe to start with, to kind
of introduce some of the things we're talking
about, many of us can imagine situations in
which the inputs seem to be the same.
It might be a situation where a patient goes
to two different doctors with the same symptoms
or a driver is driving.
And there is a situation with some pedestrians
and vehicles where the circumstances seem
to be the same.
But there's something we call human judgment
that is applied, which sometimes gets each
individual to make a different decision, whether
it's driving, whether it's about a diagnostic
test that a doctor wants to do in in your
world.
How do you start quantifying this X factor
of human judgment and thinking about it in
a way that we can start making some observations
about it?
Speaker 5: Let's first start by double clicking
on what you call human judgment here, because
in the examples you've taken, yes, we have
human judgment in some cases.
We also have human judgment, but we don't
mind variation.
So say we are deciding, you know, what what
hotel we prefer in a foreign city or what
dish we prefer in the menu.
It's fine if you and I disagree.
That's not something where we where we expect
uniformity.
The problem that we've been writing about
in lawyers is when we have human judgments
on which we expect uniformity, on which we
think there is a correct answer.
For instance, as you said, when the patient
is visiting a doctor, the diagnosis should
not be a matter of opinion.
It should not be a matter of taste or preference.
It should be a matter of professional judgment.
And we pretty much expect that different doctors
would come to the same judgment.
And the problem is quite often they don't.
And that's what we call noise, the unwanted
variability in human judgments.
Speaker 1: What are the factors that we what
are the categories of factors that can create
these differences?
You know, I remember reading about in fact,
it may have been a Daniel Kahneman book.
Now, I don't remember offhand about sentencing
in criminal cases and how one factor that
affected sentencing was, is it close to lunchtime
or is it after lunchtime?
In other words, how hungry is the judge seemed
to play a role in determining a sentence?
What what category would that type of of a
judgment discrepancy fall under and what types
of categories are there?
Speaker 5: So this category, the example you
take here, which is a famous study of judicial
decisions, is what we call occasion noize
occasion.
Noise is the fact that the same people looking
at the same facts on two different occasions
will sometimes not have exactly the same judgment.
So a judge looking at the same defendants
tried for the same case before lunch or after
lunch will not have exactly the same judgment.
And by the way, this is true also of factors
such as the temperature, whether the weather
is sunny or rainy, whether the judge's favorite
football team won or lost the game the previous
day, and whether the previous cases that the
judge looked at were favorable or unfavorable.
So there are a lot of factors that are going
to influence the judge that are completely
extraneous to the case that should have nothing
to do with the case but influence it.
That's what we call occasion noise.
It's variation within the person.
And we can all feel this when we when we know,
oh, I made that decision because I was in
a bad mood.
If I think back on it, I would have made a
different decision.
Now that I'm in a good mood, that's that's
fairly intuitive.
We're aware of that.
Who probably underestimates it, but we're
aware of it.
That's one of the categories.
Speaker 1: Can you give us some of the other
other categories?
Speaker 5: Sure.
So another category which is relatively easy
to wrap your mind around is if you take again
the example of judges that people have different
average levels of severity.
So some judges are going to be tough hanging
judges, other judges are going to be more
lenient.
They're, you know, the bleeding hard judges
who feel for the defendant.
If you give these two judges the same 20 different
cases, of course, each of the twenty cases
is different.
But the average sentence that the bleeding
heart judge gives is going to be a lot less
than the average sentence.
And the judge gives.
That's what we call level noise.
And then there is a third category, which
is a bit harder to wrap your mind around,
but which is actually the most important one.
And it's easy to to see if you think again,
if the judges take these two judges, the lenient
one and the and the tough one is not only
do they disagree on the average level of their
sentences, they're also going to disagree
on each case.
If you ask them to rank the cases from the
the worst case to the least civilly punishable
case, they are not going to agree on the ranking
because basically they have different tastes.
They are different individuals.
They have different life experiences.
They have different preferences.
They may have different political opinions.
Basically, they see different things in the
cases that they look at.
They have different patterns of judgment and
that's what we call pattern lawyers.
So we have occasion.
Those we have level knows we have patronized.
When you put all those things together, you
have a lot of reasons for judgments that should
be identical, ideally to, in fact, differ
and differ quite a bit.
Speaker 1: So there are people who are maybe
technocratic by nature who when you present
this to them, they would come up with a solution,
maybe when it comes to the sentencing question,
or maybe when it comes to when a patient comes
in with certain complaints, what's the path
of testing that that should be done where
they would essentially say we need to eliminate
some of this variability, we will use a computer
program of some kind, artificial intelligence.
We put in the inputs and it tells us this
person should get seven years in prison and
everybody gets seven years in prison or this
patient should get the CAT scan.
This one should not.
That would be one approach to this.
Is that does that account for the true nature
of complexity with many of these situations,
or would that solution leave something out
that's important?
Speaker 5: Well, there is a difficult tradeoff
to make here.
What is guaranteed is that if you do what
you just described, you will eliminate the
noise.
Yes, because whatever system, whatever rule,
whatever algorithm, whatever formula you put
in place is going to be noise free.
And that's why it's often when you actually
measure the performance of algorithms and
rules and so on, it's often quite good because
it eliminates the noise, the level noise,
the occasional is the better noise.
It basically makes sure that when you have
the same inputs, you will have the same output.
Now, does that make does that necessarily
make rules and algorithms a good thing?
No, because noise is not the only way you
can be wrong.
You can also have bias.
So suppose to take an extreme but not completely
crazy case that you have a rule that says
anyone who's been sentenced of this particular
crime gets exactly this punishment, or anyone
who's been sentenced three times of a felony
goes to jail for life.
Three three strikes and you're out.
Yes.
Well, you've eliminated noise there, at least
if you apply the rule.
But a lot of people would say you've created
another form of error, which is a form of
bias, which is that you are.
Giving too severe a sentence to a lot of people
who would not deserve that sentence.
Yes, you've eliminated the unwanted variability
between people who have committed the same
three crimes, but you've added a lot of bias
in the form of unwanted severity against people
who have committed three not so bad crimes.
So there's a trade off between how accurate
and how unbiased an algorithm or a rule can
be and the fact that it will be noise free
because that tradeoff is a difficult one.
There is going to be lots of cases where,
in fact, you will have to continue to resort
to human judgment.
You cannot replace it with a rule and therefore
you need to try to make it better, less noisy
without eliminating the human component
Speaker 1: where where biases affect human
judgment.
Sometimes it has been argued that being aware
of these biases can help mitigate their impact.
So whether it's availability bias or whether
it's confirmation bias, that understanding
that this is something that might impact our
judgment helps us to reduce it when it comes
to noise, is is it is awareness also useful
in mitigating it in an individual or is it
less useful?
Speaker 5: So first of all, for bias, there
isn't actually a lot of evidence that simply
being aware of the biases is an effective,
lasting, sustainable way to reduce your biases.
It doesn't work that well.
Awareness is good.
It makes you more careful, but it's not in
itself sufficient for noise.
It's even worse.
OK, because here's the problem of noise.
You don't know which way it's going to make
you go wrong.
You don't know of all the possible sources
of noise, of everything that affects you in
a particular occasion or for your individual
preferences that could be different from somebody
else's.
Of all the factors that can influence you
on a particular case, you don't know in what
direction it's going to make you go wrong.
So you need to actually take a stance that
we call decision hygene.
That is a form of prevention against noise
without knowing how noise is going to affect
you.
The reason we call it decision hygiene, which
is slightly off-putting and that's intentional,
is that we we liken this to washing your hands.
When you wash your hands, you don't know what
germs you're eliminating.
You you're not saying, oh, this is the covid
virus and this is the flu virus.
And if you have these two particular things
and in fact, if you're successful, you will
never know what problem you've prevented.
But you know that it's good discipline, that
it's good practice, that it's good hygiene.
Likewise, everything that you do in your decision
making process, ahead of the decision, ahead
of time to make your decision process more
disciplined, is going to improve the quality
of your decisions because it's going to make
you less noisy
Speaker 1: when it comes to institutions versus
individuals.
Noise at the institutional level sometimes
can lead to what what some call systemic types
of biases.
You could imagine how noise and human judgment
might lead to racial discrimination in housing
decisions, for example, or transportation
decisions about where should the stops for
the subway line be, which could be influenced
by all of these types of factors.
Do you approach institutional decision making
noise differently than, for example, a doctor
or a driver making a decision about an individual
patient, for example?
Speaker 5: We actually view the doctor as
part of an institution.
When you only see one doctor, you will never
know if your doctor is noisy.
You go to a doctor, your doctor tells you
you have the flu, you go home, you take your
medicine and it gets better or it doesn't
get better.
You will never know whether another doctor
in the same hospital would have told you,
no, it's not the flu, it's covid-19.
Right.
Or it's not the flu.
It's something else.
So if you think about who should take care
of noise, it's actually always the institution.
As individuals, we can try to make ourselves
more disciplined.
But the institution, whether it's the hospital
or the justice system, the the organization
that takes care of hiring individuals or the
company that has a hiring process, all those
institutions should try to reduce both the
noise and the biases in their decisions.
And if they put in place good decision hiring
practices, they will reduce noise.
They will also at the same time reduce the
sorts of systemic biases that you are talking
about, because when you put in place good
decision practices, you will make your decisions
less exposed, less dependance, less sensitive
to the biases of individuals.
Speaker 1: The last thing I wanted to talk
about is whether there are some cases where
we're maybe both noise and bias are good in
the sense that they are sort of what makes
us uniquely human in the example that I will
give is as we learn more about autonomous
vehicles and the.
Decisions that drivers are sometimes making
almost intuitively in a fraction of a second
about, for example, merging in a rotary or
traffic circle, whether it's the right time
or it's not the right time or about getting
through a yellow light or not, this is something
that it's really been reduced to.
It's happening in a very, very small amount
of time.
And we're sort of intuitively considering
the position of pedestrians and how far we
are from the light.
In some of these cases, there will be variability,
but it seems that that it's actually quite
hard to replicate it accurately with an artificial
intelligence or with computers.
What about those cases where noise seems to
be a sort of uniquely human ability to make
these judgment calls in a very small amount
of time?
Speaker 5: So we wouldn't call this noise.
We would say that those quick decisions that
you're talking about are system one decisions.
They are decisions that are made without consciously
thinking about what you're doing.
And there are based on a lot of learning that
has taken place, they can be excellent decisions
that you can have great instincts.
If you have been well-trained, you can have
acquired expertize at something.
So if you are the Formula One driver, your
your instincts to drive a Formula One car
are extraordinarily fine, extraordinarily
fine tuned, and you're able to make your decisions
in a fraction of a second.
That quite likely would be difficult for a
computer to make.
Now, is this a case of noise?
You wouldn't call this a case of noise in
the sense that those decisions are hypothetically,
as you as you describe them, good.
They're actually consistent.
The the expert would make the same decision.
A lot of times when faced with the same situation
where we would see noise is when a person
making a decision is not consistent and different
people are not consistent with each other
in the decisions that they make.
And that creates variability.
That is not the case in the example you were
talking about, where presumably there are
maybe humans who are better than machines.
That will remain the case for a long time
in a lot of important decisions.
Speaker 1: So those it's really a different
category altogether.
Speaker 5: Yes.
And there will be we I don't want to give
the impression that that machines are the
solution to everything and clearly they aren't.
And that's why we were writing this book that
actually talks not about how to eliminate
human judgment, but how to replace it.
There will be lots of decisions that we will
want humans to make, either because it's too
difficult to have a machine that makes it
or because we don't want the machine to make
it in our place, because we we care about
dealing with the different human being.
We want to give people a sense of agency.
We want to give people who interact with the
decision the dignity of dealing with the human
being and not with the machine.
There are lots of very valid reasons to retain
human judgment.
And when that is the case, we need to make
sure that those judgments, if they cannot
be the sort of expert snap second judgments
that you are talking about, that they are
made in a considered careful way so that they
are less noisy, more just and less prone to
error.
Speaker 1: That that that makes a lot of sense.
We've been speaking about the book Noise A
Flaw in Human Judgment, co-written by Daniel
Kahneman, Cass Sunstein and our guest today,
Professor Olivia Khubani.
So great having you on.
I really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 5: Thank you very much, David